foreign
Manitoba Canada what's up Jody
hi
how are we doing
oh I'm pretty nervous
um I am too I'm terrible at this so
we'll be nervous together it'll be fine
all right that sounds good
you sound like you totally believe me
all right so what's up
well um okay I guess I'll start with my
question
um
how do I make a decision about the
future of my marriage when fear
paralyzes me from making any kind of
decision
what decision do you have to make
um
basically if we
continue
um
on this path or you know if I if I walk
away from this relationship you're being
super vague
okay well maybe I'll give you a little
bit of History here
um so I met my husband
um when I was 29 he's seven years older
than me we've been married for about
nine years now
um I had a child I brought into the
relationship
um which was from just kind of a short
relationship that I had but when I
discovered I was pregnant
um this father just rejected everything
so she left at that point
um so it had been about a year later and
I met my husband and I I guess you know
my my self-esteem was really low and I
probably had no business getting into a
relationship at that point but you know
here was this nice stable guy he had a
job he had a house he treated me with
respect and and I wasn't used to having
that so you know I I let him in
um we did have a bit of a rocky
relationship that was kind of on again
off again because I I you know I kept
thinking like no this isn't what I want
but you know the alternative was I I was
alone and and I just wanted somebody to
be there
um
so you know we dated for about a year
and then we got engaged and you know
immediately after we got engaged I was
like oh my God this relationship is is
just moving forward and and I'm not sure
that this is the right thing
um but I just kind of you know stifled
those feelings and you know got swept up
in the excitement of planning a wedding
um so we had this huge lavish wedding
that of course we could not afford
um we decided to buy a house we went on
a honeymoon and sort of when we came
back and settled into normal everyday
life
um that's when things got really really
hard
and when you say really hard I want to
get real real clear here
really hard like he's abusive
he or or or or really hard like
you don't find him attractive
you don't like him really hard in that
you know we we started arguing a lot
a lot of new marriages so like what this
seems more existential
on my part my husband travels a lot for
work so I was left
alone and I guess it wasn't what I had
been expecting out of married life I I
thought I would have this companion I
thought our relationship would be
um just wonderful and but but
I
don't
um
I'm gonna take a risk here I don't think
that the relationship is the problem
I really don't I don't think you like
Jody
because
you had a picture of a thing and it was
gonna look like this and it ended up
looking like something else yeah and
it's taken you 10 years
almost a decade
and when someone says I got left alone I
was lonely
my first question is why'd you choose
loneliness
so after your husband decides he's going
to be on the road or has to be on the
road for his job a yeah you didn't have
that conversation which I get man a lot
I didn't have that skill set until 15
years after being married to say hey I
need this or I want this
I get that and you didn't choose to find
relationships in community with other
people which I think all married couples
need
so it sounds like you were expecting
this person I it's not like you married
a ghost is what it sounds like
you married a fantasy
and nobody there is no ghost or fantasy
that can be both super attractive and
and support you and not bother you but
also be there for you and be your
companion but not too much you see what
I'm saying it's a moving Target and
that's you anytime someone's dealing
with a moving Target
it's almost always them trying to use
external means to fill internal holes
so what is it about Jody that you don't
trust
um
I don't know I've been rejected
a lot in my life
um
relationships are really hard
for me
um me too out there me too yeah
yeah
so here's my promise to you I promise
you this
this may not be your this may not you
may not stay married to this guy long
term that's another conversation another
call
if you leave him today
and meet somebody in three months you're
going to be in this exact same boat in
five to ten years
because you haven't dealt with you
yeah
is that fair
yeah that's fair
so let me ask you this one terrifying
scary question what do you want Jody
and I'm asking that in in the bound
context of you're a mom and you're a
wife
what do you want
peace
okay that comes from the inside out
yeah
what are you unpeaceful about
um
I don't know it's just
like I've completely shut down I
things that you know should should bring
me joy just don't
um
I've heard you talk on the show about
people that escape you know on Facebook
and Instagram and and just kind of
scroll their entire lives away and and
that's me to achieve like I just
I just try to escape
and it's not from some it sounds like
you're not escaping from a dragon it
sounds like you're escaping from smoke
and it's it's easier to escape a dragon
because you can see it
yeah and this feels like it's enveloping
you is that fair
yeah
you're describing to a t depression
have you gone to talk to somebody
um I actually from the time that I wrote
your show to like this call today
um I actually have one appointment with
um with a counselor good
here's what I want you to do have you
had that at that meeting yet
yeah I've had one meeting so far how was
it
um
promising okay
I think there's a really bright light at
the other end of this
but I think that you're
um I talk a lot about anxiety and OCD
and those kind of things one thing I
don't play around with is depression
just because I just look at the data
okay and it's that one's a tough one
just to think your way out of or just to
go act your way out of usually you have
to sit down with somebody and be for and
be honest often for the first time in
your life
and here's here's the goal here
Joy yes but we're looking at creating a
life worth living
and you sound like somebody who's
allowed life to happen to them for a
long long time
and you've loved parts of it and you
also thought different parts of it would
feel differently than they actually do
and there's parts of it you don't like
that don't fit your picture of what you
would what you would do Changing
Partners right now I don't know that
that fixes that it might I don't see it
yeah that's for you and your therapist
I talked to somebody recently who quit
their job as a high flute job and had
been struggling with some depression
some anxiety and quit their job and
things felt good for a few weeks and
then all of a sudden it's like oh the
depression anxiety is back and it's like
yeah
he's not an external an external
stressor would fix an internal Challenge
and it won't sometimes it'll help
sometimes changing the context will help
but
this is a long time isn't it
yeah yeah
I've been on
and I just feel like you know every time
kind of life gets harder and I go you
know to the doctor and it's just like up
my dosage up my dosage right so but but
listen when you go to the doctor to stop
feeling bad that's for most that's the
only tool they've got
and the goal right now is to not stop
feeling bad
the goal is let's build a life worth
living
and those are different things when you
tell your husband
that you're on the fence about right now
I just need you to do this and this and
this because they make those things make
me feel bad or I don't feel good I don't
feel Joy
that's different than hey would you be a
part of changing everything with me
yeah that's a totally different one is
an invitation to an adventure and the
other is a is a phone book of rules and
regulations
and that phone book moves and it pushes
and it goes and it goes
um the adventure is never ending
and so here's my promise to you go to
the counselor
and be honest about not what you want to
stop feeling as much and be honest of
course about that but also be highly
intentional intentional about asking for
skills to build a life that you want to
be a part of
and that will include really hard
conversations with your current husband
that'll include hard conversations with
your kid that'll include new boundaries
that will include you doing different
things hard things like getting up every
morning and exercise think you'll you
know whatever it will require you to
change too
it will not be easy
but you're at a stage now everybody
listening this is a stage when somebody
needs professional help
this isn't something I'm going to solve
on the radio
um this isn't something you're going to
solve over a cup of coffee and this
isn't one of those things you tell
somebody you just need to you know think
more about nope
it says all Hallmarks of somebody who's
struggling with depression
and the light on the other side of this
thing is has a brightness that you can
only imagine Jody
to go sit with this therapist be honest
be direct
and be specific about changing your life
we're rooting for you my sister